I would like to have a career like Lady
gaga
in terms of music and talent and Kim
Kardashian in terms of entrepreneurship
I'm gonna be our house just wait how do
you feel I feel really proud of myself
also my sister's here would you like me
to bring her in we would love to say hi
to Juliet I just need him here hello it
was a hard secret to keep but it was
just great seeing her become like this
super amazing confident sexy the kitty
grown woman and she is doing the sexy
thing oh yeah yeah you you grew up with
your sister obviously you think is it
weird to see her in this sexy grown
woman sort of days of life the thing is
is I've watched her grow up she was
capable she's always been so mature and
amazing it's kind of like yes the rest
of the world gets to see the person who
I'd grown up with like this amazing
confident person
I mean and you guys have a very unique
quarantine situation would you tell us a
little bit about where you are and who
it is you're all holed up with okay well
our parents actually are undergoing a
divorce right now so we have hit no it's
okay
they're actually a lot happier sometimes
divorces are better for the whole family
but my dad has his girlfriend and her
daughter as well as my mom's girlfriend
and then we also took in a transgender
boy who was abused by his family so we
have ten people in the house
yeah how is it going is everyone getting
along are there little squabbles here
and there yeah but I mean it's it's
family fights everybody fights and we
always fix it by the end of the night I
love yous it's all good
are you adjusting to this new normal of
this blended family that you're now a
part of I'll admit it was really hard
for me in the beginning why I don't know
it's just like it was like it was like
the snap of the finger and you know
endgame happens and we were in this new
very very new situation I mean for me it
was hard because my parents were the
ideal of you know like growing up I
always wanted a relationship like theirs
and then you kind of find now oh I guess
it wasn't that great but I mean you
learn how to adjust to it you realize
that love can be a fickle thing like
just because it doesn't work between
these two people
something beautiful came out of it they
have four kids that are you know working
and strong and now we haven't even
bigger family to spread the Evancho love
obviously we grew up watching you on a
GT so you're no stranger to competition
shows what made you join the masked
singer it was the perfect opportunity
for me to clear my slate as the girl
who's ten years old and a big singer and
sort of grow into the 20 year old who is
you know an adult like everybody else
you know they have all sorts of sides
it's not just angelic there's also sexy
and strong and fierce you know and it
was so fun to finally get to show that I
want it that was the goal of the show
for me do you feel like you've been
pigeon-holed and kind of you know put
into this box where people want to think
of you as a kid forever but you're
actually yearning to do like very
grown-up stuff oh absolutely it is hard
because I want to be taken seriously so
desperately and you know for years I
would post a photo of me and even just a
tank top and I would get comments like
where's Jackie going that's this is not
the Jackie me no yeah of course not I'm
20 not 10 do you ever fear that kind of
switching over crossing genres or
steering more towards pop abandon those
dedicated fans I do fear that and that's
the biggest challenge of you know being
so public so young and I mean nobody
makes decisions at ten year old ten
years old that are set in stone you know
I do not want to neglect those loyal
fans who have been with me from the
beginning and I will always have that
love for classical crossover it's not
like that'll disappear but I hope that
my fans will decide to grow with me not
against me can you complete this
sentence for me I would like to have a
career like like I would like to have a
career like Lady gaga
in terms of music and talent and Kim
Kardashian in terms of entrepreneurship
Wow that is a great long combo there
I'm gonna be our house just wait yeah I
mean like what's the plan well for me
the plan and I've actually learned this
from the Matt singer is that nothing is
off-limits
so for me my plan is gonna be doing
anything and everything that I have the
urge to do whether that's acting whether
that's writing songs in any genre I want
and recording them and putting them out
there I want to create videos and just
you know get all these ideas that are
wrapped in my head and put them out to
the world you know I want to be able to
do everything
modeling possibly if I'm tall enough
ever acting you know um guys the limit
yeah make up lines who knows you
mentioned Lady Gaga and Kim Kardashian
have you spoken with either of them no I
really wish I might dream every time
someone asked me who I wanted to do it
with it was always Lady Gaga it still is
but I did have the offer dressing for
Kim Kardashian's wedding once really
hurt her Kanye wedding which wedding no
the one right before Kanye the Kris
Humphries wedding Kim asked me knit the
wedding why didn't you because I was so
young back then in my parents we're like
mmm maybe not the best right now right
here old Jackie does she regret that yes
absolutely
how cool that be maybe you can sing at a
Kim and Kanye anniversary party
something in the future we're birthday
party for one of the kids I love that
I respect the business and the devotion
to the business that that family has I
mean I know everyone likes to look at
them as a joke but in reality there are
smart people I mean you're on et do you
want to look in the camera and and ask
him if you guys can hang or do something
where you can pick her brain or maybe
team oh yes Kim Kardashian I would love
to learn some secrets about creating a
business empire really I love that
because that's all I want my life you're
like such an inspiration to me when it
comes to that stuff and every
so like also you're a really good mom I
can tell I respect that I love that as
busy as you are is there time for dating
do you have dreams of being a mom
someday
there's definitely time for dating for
me at least I am I do have a boyfriend
still early stages but so far as we know
I grew up with him actually oh so okay
the hometown friend yes be in the public
eye no I think that for a lot of my life
I'm going to prefer dating people that
aren't in the public eye because I think
that it causes a lot of problems you
like what like you know egos and you
know all these beautiful young girls
throwing themselves at my husband thank
you and I have to ask obviously we're in
a strange quarantine situation how is
the relationship and dating going
through that he only lives ten minutes
from me so he actually gets to come over
every once in a while after hosing
himself down with a lot of cleaning
supplies so it's going really well you
tell us aren't you working on new music
and what's gonna sound like a lot of it
is you know very pop Billie Eilish makes
a lot of del Rey sort of things what are
you writing about are you writing about
being in love some songs are about the
love others are about heartbreak and a
lot of just you know feeling alone but
that you're not also stuff oh my god who
broke Jackie Evancho is hard the guy who
dumped me on snapchat after he cheated
on me huh what happened there it's a
long story but if you up its you know
who you are I do want to ask you because
it is a big year it's an election year
if you were asked to perform at the
inauguration again would you
ah you know that really depends I've
learned from the last experience that
I don't want to be one of those
celebrities that has my political views
out to the world although I will always
fully wholeheartedly accept you know the
LGBTQ community I have all sorts of
family members from it and there's no
way I would ever turn my back on them
but at that time I was 14 15 years old
and being told what to do you know
trying to reboot the career so I have no
idea if you decided to your 20 year old
woman you make your own decisions do you
think Juliette would support it and all
your other family members who are LGBT I
think that whatever decision I make they
know that I will have thought really
well through and they also know I would
never do anything to intentionally upset
my family members or hurt their feelings
or neglect anybody so I think they'll
always be comfortable of my decisions
because they will never go against them
charlie final words give us that
dangerous woman cover that you did the
first week it was great I loved every
second of it something they go
[Music]